So the GPU code will have two parts,
one of which runs on the GPU, one of which runs on the CPU.
So we're going to start by saying what do we have to express in the GPU part of this program.
And we only need to express something very simple, the idea that out = in X in.
Now this kernel that we write for the GPU doesn't say anything about the level of parallelism.
If you remember, kernels look like serial programs.
So the idea of the fact we're going to do this 64 times, not expressed in the GPU program at all.
What does the CPU do?
Well, it has to do the allocation of the memory, copying the data to and from the GPU,
but the important part in terms of the computation is that the CPU launches the kernel.
This is where the parallelism of threads is expressed.
The CPU program will look something like, okay, let's launch a square kernel,
we're going to launch 64 threads, and the arguments to those threads are
an output array and an input array.
Just to get our terminology straight,
what we're doing here is launching a kernel called square kernel on 64 threads
and each of those 64 instances of the kernel will perform one
of the 64 square operations that we need to do.
Now, one question that may be puzzling you is
what good is it to launch 64 instances of the exact same program?
So here's how we answer that question.
Each thread that we launch knows which thread it is.
We're going to call that the thread index.
So if you launched 64 threads, one of them knows it's thread 0, one of them knows it's thread 1, and so on.
Then you can assign thread number n to work on the nth element of the array.
So let's summarize here.
You write your kernel so that it will run on one thread at a time.
Then you will launch many threads, each of which will run that kernel independently.